when he could lose it when he scores
when he scored in double figures in the
playoffs there five and one curry trade
ball deflected picked up by Leonard
Danny Greene wide open allow the play to
develop so he forces Bogut to be in
position to help
it creates the wide open shot curry on
the drive off the glass gets to the
floor
Bogut just picked up his first foul was
on him not cooked Gasol gets it drives
down a lane nice bounce pass and Leonard
and Gasol eight points Zack the curry
inside folded perry doing a little bit
of everything
well they'd like to enter the ball to
green and make him be the playmaker then
fleet on the wrong side of curry leads
to a back cut a catch and a drop-off to
the ever so valuable
[Music]
Leonard gets away from Paulo and throws
a tip and Kawhi Leonard just blowing by
them as Oracle Arena gets on their feet
hurry long distance okay
everything goes tonight getting looks
and capitalizing Curry in the paint
planet pushing the pace kicks it out
Danny Green pucks it in Danny great from
downtown stream on green
this the second field goal from draymond
Green Leonard trying to get the ball
Curry's on him here comes the
double-team Venters trying to split
almost travel ban quick throws it up
[Applause]
for they doubled and VanFleet gets it
and knocks it home air ball here comes
curry
hurry shake and bake three-pointers
[Applause]
believe will play by Steph Curry
understanding he's got to be aggressive
forces of defense to collapse and Gasol
the rebound Larry
Leonard running the floor and lays it up
and in cousins four points a couple of
rebounds re looking for some room
the floater back has good
[Applause]
Leonard for three knocks it down eight
three-pointer of the game for Toronto
[Applause]
sorry
foul line jumper